so who came out with its fourth
installment of into the dark and it went
a little something like this
after puka success I was really looking
forward to this one but damn I just
can't do it guys I can't give you some
half-assed ending explain video where I
talk about mirrors for 10 minutes
seriously this movie has more mirrors in
it than Paris Hilton's house so I've
decided to make a new series called
think storey takedowns I wish I could
tell you what this movies about but you
don't even find out until 42 minutes
into it that's nothing much at all yes
for 42 minutes nothing happens there's
no action just four girls in a room
talking about whether their friend bang
Leonardo DiCaprio or not they at least
have the decency to change locations to
asana where they talk even more about
crap that doesn't matter at all to the
plot in all honesty this movie could
probably be condensed to 10 to 15
minutes but it was as if the producer
said hey we need to stretch this out and
oh can we have it set all in one
location it was so glaringly obvious
that this movie was constrained by its
budget and when that seeps into the
story you start to get problems but it's
not just the pacing that has problems
the characters are a complete mess
so at that 42 minute mark we finally
learned what this movie is about four
girls decide to reunite on New Year's
only for three of them to tie up the
other and make her confess to killing a
fifth girl she mercilessly bullied into
committing suicide years ago and yes
it's that convoluted and yes there are
many problems first of all these girls
have no exit plan they commit not only
kidnapping but assault to one of the
most up-and-coming social media stars
how do they expect to get out of this
and what if she refuses like she
obviously will are they gonna kill her
of course not so Alexis our main
characters big plan is to dress her up
like old Greg come on Craig yeah that'll
do it Alexis you got her now and this is
where things go completely off the rails
Kayla the only somewhat reasonable
character in this entire film rushes off
to the bathroom not being able to take
what's going on and Alexis follows
leaving Chloe and Danielle all alone now
Chloe is one of these stupidest
characters I have ever seen in any movie
ever
she decides to free Danielle after
danielle promises her a segment on her
new TV show like you actually believe
her you just tied her up and were
complicit in a crime you dumb-dumb her
character arc is completely bonkers she
goes from Alexis's side to Danielle's
then from just wanting to scare the
girls they end up locking in the sauna
for a bit to flat out wanted to murder
them then feel sorry when she actually
does kill Kayla then - feeling okay
about it she is all over the map and my
favorite is how Danielle convinces Chloe
to murder the others just by saying you
wouldn't want them to spread rumors
about us would you yes the old they
might spread rumor so you should murder
them technique but even more troublesome
is our protagonist Alexis she is so
extremely unlikable and unsympathetic
it's hard to root for her maybe we're
supposed to feel bad because of her scar
that she's a struggling babysitter but
you could probably take that out of the
movie and it wouldn't change anything
and speaking of change her character
doesn't go through any she basically has
this plan goes through with it and
doesn't learn anything along the way and
if we're gonna talk about the ending
where she takes over as
yells Protege - don't even get me
started how did she get away with all
this there were like three dead people
in her house and her telling me people
aren't like hmm maybe she had something
to do with this
and even though alexis has been talking
in this video for over a minute when we
pull back it shows the video has only
been playing for 10 seconds I guess
that's the type of service you get on
totally tubular but let's get back to
some more stupid [ __ ] like Kayla's car
breaking down right outside Alexis's
house right outside what who's like the
writer was like okay we need to have it
so that they can't use the car but we
need to get them there what can we do
Oh make it break down right when they
get there convenient or how about the
glass in every window of this home has
been specially tempered someone falls
out a window in your home and the
logical thing to do is temper all the
glass where the parents like hey we
don't want another suicide kids running
out our windows let's just be safe and
install bulletproof glass in case anyone
else wants to kill themselves again what
and speaking of death that kills in this
movie are pretty lame nothing new or
exciting it's all stuff we've seen in
other horror movies like knocking her
head or getting stabbed and I think the
editor kind of knew this because in
order to make the death of Chloe seem
more shocking because she just kind of
tumbles down the stairs and dies they
did this I laughed out loud with the
quick cuts of that music but the deaths
are equally predictable because the
director uses this technique called
Chekhov's gun way too liberally so for
those of you don't know Chekhov's gun
basically means if you show something
like a gun you better see it fired later
on and damn do they use it here where
the camera just lingers on a set of golf
clubs for an awkward amount of time hmm
I wonder if those will come into play
later on or how about these knives hmm
also why does Alexis throw Danielle's
phone nearly smashing it don't they need
that phone for their plan to expose
Danielle on her own Instagram I mean
they could use someone else's phone to
log in but what if she doesn't know her
password and last but not least for a
horror movie there's almost no tension
here because in order to have tension we
the audience
need to have some piece of information
that the characters do not for example
and carry how we know this bucket of
blood might fall but Kari doesn't that's
tension but because every characters
motivations are hidden or extremely
unclear for most of the film there's
almost none of this into the last 20
minutes of the movie so what did you
think did you like this heaping pile of
garbage should I do more takedown videos
leave a comment below and make sure to
smash that like button as if it were
made of tempered glass and until next
time remember daddy loves you very much